what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey this is
unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone do we just become best
friends yep
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of
unlocks with your favorite sisters
sophia and sistine stallone
happy tuesday everyone yes
i hope you are hungover from the weekend
and i hope
you are having a great tuesday guess
what's after tuesday sophia
wednesday there we go we're on the same
page how is everyone doing just
this is like your little daily check-in
are you guys doing okay
did you have a good bowl of cereal for
breakfast i hope you guys are
hitting the treadmills i how are you
doing sistine
first and foremost i want to ask wow
great in front
um how am i doing i'm good you know
sometimes i wake up
just very sad for no reason and today
was not one of those days so i'm doing
fabulous uh can i tell you how i'm
feeling and since we're on on wax and i
said this is the scene
i'm gonna be very straight up i'm in a
shitty mood now
oh yeah you know but like i don't think
everyone else knows so just letting you
know
i am in a bad mood and i'm fine saying
that because i'm just gonna be very
honest and i don't think i can just like
[ __ ] my way and act like i'm just
doing perfect
but you know when you get just
bad news which i got this morning and it
just kind of ruins your day
and it's really hard i think for me to
get out of that
headspace like i know i have a job too
so we're shooting this podcast and i'm
gonna go full blown about it and like
make it the best i can
um because you do have to separate when
it comes to work and how you're feeling
yeah but i just like i'm
you know i just this whole day i've been
trying to like make myself feel better
but it's really really hard to
and i don't know why sometimes i think
it's okay just to sit with being sad
though
you know what i mean i think as human
beings sometimes we try to
whenever we're feeling bad fix the
problem right away
and i'm not saying wallow for a week
straight but like i sometimes think it's
okay just to be sad
and like let that ride and then maybe
you'll feel better after you know
do you don't don't try to fix it today
because
um because i tried and honestly you
scared me a little bit
so i think i know she's just assisting
came up and she was i don't
remember what you said i ran away like
actually yeah
i'm in a feisty mood honestly things
little things are annoying me
i was like tearing up an hour ago i'm
just
it's accepted and i completely agree
with that and i think that
there is a time where when it doesn't
get involved in the things you have to
do like your job or you have like a
lunch that you need to go to or
something that is
requires you to be there and you need to
be your best self then you need to
grow up and do the thing you need to do
but
yeah you know what guys if you're having
a bad day
just like i am have a bad day
try not to be rude to your family like i
was rude to sistine
just sometimes like sometimes i need to
take it out but something that could
possibly cheer you up
what what honestly if it
no it's not this is a joke no
why do you think everything i do is just
because i feel like we're going to say
something
that's just not going to make me happier
and just doing something that makes you
happier
and i won't say it oh no say it though
because i kind of want to know
i'll say it to the podcasters i mean the
listeners out there
i'll say it to the listeners um right
before the zoom call
i i like so every time there's um
our podcast is on a new platform like i
just saw that it was on
audible uh from amazon and so i like to
just look at reviews on every sort of
platform because i am a stalker of
myself
and i just typed it unwaxed into the
search bar and then i went to images
and it's so funny because
it'll be a photo of us and then just
like a billion photos of dental floss
and then like a photo of us it's just us
with a [ __ ] ton of
unwaxed dental floss wait is that a
thing on
oh yeah i guess like not waxed so
funny i love that we're just associated
with dental floss now i i think
that maybe we should sponsored by unlock
stencil floss
yeah that was funny should i look a
little better it's really funny
i will but what do you do to um for
yourself
whenever you're like we're getting
serious again no yeah like what do you
okay we don't need to be serious but i'm
just kidding
what was your question i was asking what
you
normally do because like right now i
can't even watch a show or read a book
without still just being really annoyed
like even going outside makes me annoyed
i just want to wallow and i don't know
how to get out of that headspace
i always go for a long walk i feel like
that's the best way
um to distract myself and i'll listen to
a podcast or music
that makes me sad maybe i should give
this to the people i made a playlist
called shower crying doesn't count and
sometimes people always tell me you know
don't
listen to sad music when you're sad but
honestly it makes me feel better
um so i'll listen to sad music and go
for a long walk and then i'll just feel
sort of maybe i should go for a long
walk maybe that will make me feel better
just getting out of the house for a hot
second yeah
yeah what was that yeah it sounds like
no probably
i just don't want you to scare any you
know uh people just
minding their own business on the street
you know with your angry
culture i know my head's off
i might just scare some children off by
like me looking at them
but that also would be fun that could be
you know what maybe that's just going to
release my anger it's just like
projecting it onto everything else
yeah you know what you know what's good
you know what you should do for me
you're
you're staying in tonight right
yeah actually no want to know what i'm
doing
yeah what i met a new friend and she
asked to hang out
i'm so excited you guys
got a friend you have a friend and i
don't know
i don't know oh my god am i being
replaced i'm excited
um no stupid question
no you're not being well let's see who
you are with your little
funky town funky ass mood
playing like funky music so you met a
new friend and
you're getting a new friend i'm gonna
see her tonight i'm really excited
just to i love this it's almost like
going on a first date with a guy
it's like you're kind of on the dates
with these girls too you're just sort of
figuring out
if you guys mesh well at all very
excited
but i always say but also i just was
gonna say
yeah it's fun because you don't know
anything about her and you get to know
like everything new about her but it
also
pre-warning sometimes when you tell
people too much about yourself because
you could click
they might tell everyone else so you
gotta be careful you don't really know
her yet
i think it's like a first date like you
don't put all all your cards
too soon perhaps perhaps
right we'll see how it maybe i don't
know i think for guys yeah when you're
on a date with a guy yeah but
girlfriends are different maybe i think
the difference between guys and girls
are so poor opposite and girls use
information against you don't you think
that
see i'm so now that was i'm scared
i'm such a pessimistic wow i'm excited
to go out now
i'm so sorry you guys i'm in such a
funky mood
i'm literally just trying to ruin
cesine's night so that she doesn't go
out you can't reign on this parade
um speaking of friends we have an
incredible person on the podcast today
we are
so excited she is amazing she's a
businesswoman
she's hilarious she's funny we've had
years of friendship with this girl and
we cannot
wait to have her come on the podcast
we're going to talk about we talked
i'm sorry i thought you didn't know if
you're going to mention this but i was
just going to say that on our
conversation we have
really really really in-depth talks
about anxiety which i've gone through
her sobriety and instagram like reality
versus not reality
and but we get more personalized with it
i think we didn't get
very general with everything like we
tell stories and yeah you guys relate to
it
hopefully you laugh hopefully you shed a
tear and hopefully you bite someone's
face off like sophia
so actress producer writer blogger
designer youtuber podcaster move with
lauren elizabeth
social media influencer she started her
website and now lifestylehub
lovelearnelizabith.com in 2011 moved to
la and has been a boss woman ever
since she's the cutest dogs and most
aesthetically pleasing instagram
um she's opened up about her sobriety
and her anxiety her whole life she's one
of the most hilarious
vulnerable and kind people we've ever
met this is lauren elizabeth
stop it right now like first of all like
i'm going to need that
as a voice memo and it's going to be my
new alarm clock
i'll just okay i have this oh yeah i can
use it again i'll send it to you
and that's just like how you wake up
that's literally like also like your
voice is like so like soothing
like honestly everything oh my god yeah
that was like everything i needed
anymore
thank you guys i mean first of all like
i just have to say how much i adore the
two of you
like you're literally the best people on
the planet
whenever anyone's like oh my god have
you guys like have you like met like the
stallone sisters i'm like you don't
understand
like they are like the nicest most like
hilarious like you guys are just
absolutely amazing
and it says a lot that's so sweet you
know what i mean
i have to say i think i met you maybe
was it three years ago on valentine's
day
no it was four years ago now four years
ago this is exactly four
years ago i'm not kidding you this is
our four years
literally this is our four year
anniversary
i'm not even just saying this because
you're here but i do remember the very
first time i met you
i had never been so caught off guard
with kindness
like you completely opened your arms as
a friend to me
for you didn't have to but she hasn't
mentioned that so many times
yeah i mean i just want to thank you for
that because not a lot of people do that
and
you know when you're the new person in a
group and it's really hard to feel like
you fit in and you made me feel like i
fit in so i really
oh my god so thank you it was like your
energy is like
literally contagious like any time i was
running to like
like she's like
it was so funny because i remember you
like asking me stuff like about
like my business and everything and like
the first time we met and
you know obviously like not being from
la and then like meeting kids that like
grew up in la
i just like i i'm from the midwest so
it's like very easy to kind of just like
be self-deprecating and like dumb myself
down and just like be very humble
and you were just like so like actually
interested in what i did and i was like
so caught off guard i was well i think
she actually
cares no and i genuinely do because
first of all i think if you don't ask
questions from people that are doing a
good job at what they do
you're stupid because i was like oh my
god she's so smart
you said you came from the midwest i
didn't even know that by the way
can we talk about it is that so cool
when you moved to la what
motivated you to move to l.a what was
sort of your dream of coming to la
i mean it it all happened like honestly
really
organically because i started like my
quote unquote career when i was 16.
so i was literally in high school in the
suburbs of chicago
just like going to like private catholic
school and it was like a very like
traditional
high school in the sense of like
cheerleaders football players like there
wasn't like like we didn't have like
comec and like other like
like super like well-rounded clubs like
yes i'm sure they existed if someone
like listens to this and like went to my
high school they're gonna make it wasn't
like that like
okay we had a whole lecture about bill
bullying like it was a very cutthroat
school
and so it was like this weird time where
like
i just didn't feel like i wanted to like
do cheerleading anymore and like all
that stuff and my mom literally grounded
me and she was like
so you're grounded like do something
with your life like start a blog and i
was like you're so
dumb and then i like slammed my door and
like started the vlog
so oh my gosh your mom that's
my mom she was right she has that like
entrepreneurial spirit
yeah she's just like she i mean i owe
her like everything she's always pushing
me and so
there wasn't this like space of people
the monetizing content
and like doing it full time and so it
really just started as like a creative
outlet and then as the industry changed
i kind of just like changed with it like
i even went to college for a minute
and then it was like kind of you know
there was like a new wave of like you
could kind of get a manager
and like stuff like that and like to get
opportunities in la and i wanted to like
be the host of e-news so i was like this
is my chance
so it's like the same thing at one point
i know right
i mean it's like right i feel like we
all eat when you go to la you want to
so well it's like it's like you see
giuliana rancic and you're like
oh yeah like i got it like that's what i
want to do
exactly but obviously that didn't happen
so
well that's amazing because so you move
to la and then first i'll never say
never
you're still very young we still got
time we still have time
but so you move to la you start
all of these platforms right you're on
youtube you start acting
you're a big instagrammer i mean how do
you balance all of the social media
accounts because you're also really good
with engaging with your audience and
that's a lot of work
so how hard is that really yeah it's so
funny because i actually saw
this uh kind of i would say like i guess
quote unquote like micro influencer
the other day like because i like
following like a wide range of people on
instagram and i remember she was saying
like i don't understand how
you full-time creators have time to do
like this this this this this
and like all this other like normal
human stuff and
it was one of those things too where i
was like oh wow like
people actually don't realize like how
much work it is
i always used to compare it to the
example because i actually
started when i first moved to la i
didn't
want to just like move out here and just
like fingers crossed to like have me
opportunities handed so i was actually i
started
as an intern at awesomenesstv which
still exists
but it was definitely more of like a
digital space back in the day
and i worked there full time for like
almost a year
and seeing the you know the physical
building of all of these people that
worked on
literally a youtube channel like a grown
adult
that ran awesomeness tv from like a ceo
to like the social media team to the
marketing
all this stuff and i'm just like that's
the best example i could say of like
there are so many
businesses that literally have
full-blown teams for all these digital
pieces of their business and like
you know we have the same amount of
followers as those
corporations yeah exactly so it kind of
like
like opens people's eyes up a little bit
to be like do you understand how like
you know someone that maybe works for
like i don't know like juicy couture has
like five people
on their social team or whatever and
it's like i'm one person but
i do think of like engaging with people
as like i almost call it like customer
service quote-unquote because it's like
they're kind of like coming to me for
something and it's like i'm not like too
good to respond like i don't think that
myself is like quote-unquote
famous like why i do what i do is
because i like the
engaging with people and connecting with
people that was like that 16 year old
girl inside of me that wanted to like
connect outside of this bubble that i
grew up in
so if it can become like overwhelming in
a sense of like the actual content side
of it
and then just like the ocd like seeing
all the little blue dots like of unread
messages like in my dms
because like i feel like i have to click
them all like i yeah right
if it just says like liked a message
like i want the blue dot to go away
like i'm afraid but it's like having a
lot of
emails in your inbox and you're like oh
my god you gotta get rid of them
okay so that so but your podcast mood
is sort of a great direct way just to
talk to everyone
how is the response been from a lot of
your female audience i would assume
yeah i mean it's it's literally so crazy
because
i obviously have been online since like
2011 and i wanted to start a podcast for
a while
and i started it like basically
right before i decided to get sober
and like while i was going through like
entering this like super transitional
phase of my life because
i mean if you think about it if you do
the same thing every single day for like
10 years like obviously you're gonna end
up like losing your
mind and also just like i mean it's
almost like
not really getting a promotion at work
and like you you've been in your career
for 10 years like i'm only 26 but i've
been
like fully in the workforce for that
long right and so
i kind of was like i don't really know
like what works anymore and what i want
to do like i know i want to use my voice
i know i want to have a podcast because
that's the content i like to consume
so i want to make something that i like
and so
starting mood was more like oh like i'm
just like a moody person like i have so
many moods like sometimes i want to be
like
funny and crazy and sometimes i want to
be serious
i'm like i'm a moody gal like someone in
bed
and it literally totally
over like the first i would say like six
months probably went from being one
thing to like a completely other thing
partly because i was going through stuff
in my personal
life i think that what i was doing
wasn't even resonating
with the new audience anymore and like i
was self-aware enough to like
know that it's because like i wasn't
being authentic and to like take the
constructive criticism
and like instead of getting defensive be
like they're not completely wrong
and i'm gonna just do this exactly how i
want to do it
and hope for the best and now all of a
sudden it's like
this place where we have honest and open
like vulnerable conversations about
mental health like
not in a like lame way i guess like not
like you know
do you feel like you do you feel like
there's a difference between your
youtube
and your podcast yeah i think it's like
i mean obviously like there's way more
like visual
stuff obviously like not to like say
that that's the main difference but
the the visual side of youtube like
allows me to show
just like open up more conversations
about like here's
what i like wearing and like doing like
i love like home decor and i love
like organizing and like stuff like that
and so the visual aid of youtube like
allows me to have like more
fun with that stuff and like show more
of that but it's still like kind of
always centered around
like that idea of like trying to like be
your best self and like live your best
life like whether that is with like
feeling good because i'm like doing my
hair routine but i also get to like show
my hair routine
on youtube where like i don't really
talk about that as much on the podcast
unless it's like a literal mood booster
because i'm like so depressed like i
haven't showered in four days i'm like i
should probably just like get up and
shower and it makes me feel better you
know what i mean
right it sounds like you've been having
a lot of pivoting moments
especially during quarantine a lot's
been happening and
um i've been watching i i watch all your
videos like i love
you like seeing what you're up to
whether it's a style trend or your
favorite tanner
or and then you get into the real stuff
you talk about your sobriety you talk
about
your breakup you talk about being
vulnerable so i kind of want to talk
about
just like how you've been during
quarantine and and maybe what was the
hardest part about
you know being isolated for you yeah i
mean i was literally asking you guys
like before we started i was like how's
quarantine been
it's just so weird because like weird it
feel it's like we're coming up on like a
freaking
year of this and it's just i think it
doesn't seem real
it doesn't seem real like i but i also
like don't remember
like what life was like before at this
point right
right because it's it does feel so far
away like the past year has gone by so
fast but then like thinking before i'm
like i don't know
like what i used to do like to the point
where like i actually like
need to start figuring out like a new
daily routine because like i'm just like
living this like quarantine like
nightmare like over and over again but i
mean i
ended up getting sober like i would say
like
probably like two months before
quarantine
obviously with like no notion that we
were going into a global pandemic where
we couldn't leave our houses or else
probably would have like been the true
alcoholic i am and
prolonged that process and then like no
because i was like oh my god do you
think that the quarantine helped
did you think quarantine helped your
sobriety or didn't help
it definitely i mean i think i wouldn't
have been able to do it without that
like small foundation
of um like getting sober
like in real life because i'm i've been
in recovery since
december and so like i was able to go to
like in-person aaa meetings and like be
with my sponsor and stuff like that
so having that like small foundation and
then like switching everything to
virtual
it was still nice to be like you know a
lot of the people that i had like met
a little bit in these like rooms i could
now see like on the screen
and it was like a learning curve for
everyone like aaa's never been on zoom
before so it wasn't like
everyone was kind of like pivoting and
it was like honestly this really great
as much as it's like oh it would have
been so nice to be able to drink like
everyone else during quarantine like
every single day
it was like this really nice like kind
of
shift in this like sober community where
like we were all going through this like
really like obviously we're all always
going through sobriety but then like
having this like pandemic
having that like support group where
like you like have like a structure of
like how you kind of and you're all
going happy school
yeah yeah so it honestly like it ended
up
helping just because it almost like
confined me to getting sober without any
of the distractions of like actual
social life
and so it kind of gave me this good
foundation i mean i've been
sober longer in quarantine than i have
in the real world so like part of me
doesn't even
know i'm still like what are you doing
lauren thank you so proud
i actually won't even jump into that
because when
you and like announced basically that
you became sober
i had all of these thoughts in my head
like i wonder why she did it like what
made her jump into that decision it's
like a really life-changing decision
everything i feel like your whole
mindset is totally restructured
and then i thought about kids in college
and i was like there were so many kids i
saw
in college that had such an unhealthy
relationship with alcohol
that i realized like maybe they should
be sober and maybe they should talk to
someone like what were the
signs for you that you were like maybe i
should make this decision for myself
and change it's you know i think that
like i
obviously knew that i had an unhealthy
relationship with alcohol since i was
like 14. and like i grew up in a place
where i didn't even like really know
what drugs were
honestly until i like went to college
just because like i grew up in such a
bubble
but i knew what vodka was like the
moment i like
left middle school and so i always knew
that like it didn't make me feel good
and i was like always like a blackout
drinker and it was always like drinking
for the purpose of getting drunk like i
never really
learned how to socially drink like ever
and so
right but it was so normalized that like
when i came to la
and i i kind of started to feel the
repercussions of a little bit of more of
that like
hangover anxiety because i was like oh
like this isn't just with like my
my high school friends and like the
usual stuff i'm like these this is
affecting like other people and like now
i have
work and like but i still was so good at
it that i didn't totally
see a problem because again it was so
normalized and so
it got to the point where i had like one
like really really bad
like blackout and then i was obviously
in a relationship at the time and he was
like you need to figure your [ __ ] out
and i was just like i got it and
that it took me two years to even
be able to get sober like from that
point like that's how
hard and also like now it's you know
it's so nice like there's like this kind
of like sober curious movement like
people are talking about sobriety more
but even just two years ago like i
didn't
know anything about getting sober all i
knew was okay i needed for therapy
and i started therapy and i
went because i was like i just i got
super drunk there's all this drama in my
life and i need to figure it out
and it's almost like i admitting like a
little bit
of having a problem made me like drink
more and more and more and more to the
point where i was like
oh wait this is even like a bigger
problem than it was before
and you don't realize like even like i
didn't know that i was drinking besides
social anxiety until my therapist told
me i was like what are you talking about
i'm hilarious like i have social anxiety
right like because you your personality
is i would have never guessed
because your personality is so outgoing
and you're bubbly and
we we've hung out a couple times and i
just i would never have thought
but it really goes to show that you
never know what anyone is dealing with
internally
yeah it really goes to show because you
could always be happy
and the fun party person in the room but
everyone has their own [ __ ] that they're
dealing with and i want to say i'm so
proud of you for actually taking that
step and recognizing the problem and
like
you you you look amazing and like i can
actually see a difference no really in
the way that you're speaking and smiling
about it it's like
i genuinely see an incredibly big change
in you and so it's really cool
that you made this step and you had
mentioned that um you went to therapy
for it and your therapist
actually helped you recognize it was
tied to your social anxiety
so anxiety is something that we
definitely have been waiting
to actually discuss on this podcast with
you
because um sophia has dealt with anxiety
i've dealt with
minor forms of anxiety and you've been
extremely open about your anxiety
so i feel like um we should show to just
like jump into that topic a little bit
if you guys are comfortable with it
because
i certainly want to learn more
well i know because sophia was telling
i'm i think you mentioned at the
beginning of the podcast you were like
that's like how we like connected at
first
so the funniest yeah yeah you this is
the funniest thing is i
i think this was like was it two years
ago three years ago i can't totally
remember what it was but
i was at one of my points where i was
really low and it was like one of those
anxiety spirals where you're like i'm
fine i'm fine i'm fine
and then it just shoots down and you're
just like in this black hole
and i don't know what it was i don't
know if they're like the star is aligned
but i don't really watch it i didn't
watch a ton of your videos now i do i
love watching your videos
but at the time it popped up and you
were it was something you posted like
that week and you were saying literally
exactly how i felt you were talking
about
having this major anxiety like things
were just piling up piling up piling up
you'll go to therapy for like a couple
months and then you'll feel better
then you won't go and then all of a
sudden
you realize that all of this [ __ ] is so
to the ceiling that
when it comes crashing down it crashes
down and that's exactly how i was
feeling
and i literally texted um the
ex and i said hey i need to talk to
lauren just like tell her
how much she helped me because it made
me actually go back to therapy
honestly like that was the day i
remember getting that text message too
and it made me like cry on the phone
yeah i heard that when my ex-boyfriend
texted me and like sent me like a
screenshot or something was like can i
send her your number
i was like oh my god this is like the
nicest thing i've ever seen like this
makes me so happy because it's just like
it's like cestine was saying like you
don't know what someone's like going
through and like
it's like the same with like anyone that
just watches my videos because it's like
yes like i'm talking about it but like i
don't when i'm saying it like i don't
fully think like oh like i'm saying this
because like so many people are going to
relate to it i i say it because like
i just i can't sleep at night unless i'm
yeah like just being honest about it
because
you know like i hate like coming onto a
podcast and being like oh my god like
cysteine and sophia and then like in
reality like i was like crying last
night i mean you can tell like i look
like [ __ ] but
it's like i was crying an hour ago
you're so [ __ ]
like it's like one of those things
really like it's just like
like the in the state of being like
transparent because with social media is
so
it's it's [ __ ] hard and i mean i
don't know if you can relate with
anxiety but i think that like something
that like honestly makes my anxiety
worse
is unfortunately like my job and being
on social media like it's the pressure
of like so much and like i know that
obviously we grew up like totally
different ways so like
but it's still like i i get on social
media and like a lot of the times like
it makes me feel worse and less like i
make sure i'm following the right people
you know it's so funny because a lot of
my anxiety stems from
me not doing enough or me at the wrong
place or if i'm not with the right
people or if i'm just like
and i get so hard on myself and so heady
it's kind of interesting i don't know if
your anxiety was like this is when i was
born like my anxiety kind of
transitioned as i got older like it
totally like it first
went to being like i cannot be away from
my parents i was like separation anxiety
oh my god yes
my parents would go out to dinner what
would you say maybe you're six years old
yeah and they've maybe come back at 11
30 at night or 12 o'clock at night
and she'd be waiting on the stairs all
night until they got home because she
had the fear that they would
yeah or not come home all of these fears
yeah and it's kind of interesting
because then it turned into my sister so
then my parents like i didn't really
mind if they left and i got super
overprotective of my sisters and
it was one of those things like i had to
see them in bed asleep
for me to feel better and it honestly
and i never went to therapy all those
years and for some reason
i thought to myself like i could fix
this and so
i kind of did get out of that and so now
all the anxiety is just placed on me and
the things i do
and i didn't go to therapy until i was
like
13 14 and i hated it like i don't know
if that's how you felt in the beginning
like i went to so many different
therapists
i would lie to my therapist i would like
i thought it was a show i literally
thought it was like a piece of
performance art when i was like 12.
and i'm a very self-sufficient person
like i like to fix things on my own i
don't like to ask for help
i don't like people telling me like how
to fix it and it became a thing where i
was like
hitting a wall like okay sophia you're
just talking to yourself and you have
anxiety like
an anxiety person talking to like
themselves is not gonna help at all yeah
it's like so it's so funny too because
they feel like especially people with
anxiety
like we're like self-sufficient and like
we like to fix other people's problems
so we're like oh like we got this and
then in reality it's like
the blind leading the blind because it's
like you talking to your anxiety in your
head and it's like
like i can give you advice all day and
then like before i go to bed at night
like i'll forget everything i said to
you and then like start doing everything
in my own head and it's just like
there's
like you need that like outside source
and i think it helps for people like us
too that
are like you know like we're smart and
like we we i think it's
that street smart too you know it's like
we understand emotions we understand
people like social stuff whatever and so
having like an actual professional be
like no like this is
actually what anxiety is and what your
brain is doing it's like
okay i trust you because like you're a
licensed
professional and now you're helping me
understand as opposed to like a friend
just being like
you got this girl and i'm like yeah
that's so true what are you talking
about
like you know what it was also is that i
didn't even confront the idea that my
anxiety was something that i was
actually born with because i feel like a
lot of people go like
i'm so anxious i have anxiety and
anxiety but when you have true anxiety i
the best way to explain it to someone is
like it's a feeling
it's like it's not it's not just like
something that's onset it's just how i
when someone says like are you okay i'm
like
no i i just my whole body is off yeah
and i woke even if
my day is totally fine no one is
bothering me
my work is great my friends are great my
sisters are great
i'll just wake up super anxious i'm like
okay this is just this is my mind
like this is something that i have to
work through and i mean i
went to therapy and i still do
occasionally like i don't think you need
it
all the time i think you need it at
certain points in your life and i think
that
when you feel like you're good you can
reduce the amount of times you go and i
know that's helped me a lot
but it you're kind of you're like a
well-oiled machine you need to keep like
reaching
yourself you can't forget to go back and
i'm also a person that i can't stop
talking
like i have to talk about it no 100
i have a question for both of you
because obviously everyone handles it
differently and lauren you mentioned
that you deal with social anxiety
so when you're in that element and you
feel it sort of coming on
what are ways that sort of help you
bring it back down and sofia the same
question to you
i think too like what uh sophia was
saying because you know how you said
like it's like that like
feeling and because i always i mean my
therapist makes me
she always goes you know like you know
because i'm always like i don't know why
i feel this way like i don't know how i
feel
and she's always like you know you know
but it's like also you know we talk like
every single week for the past like
three however many years and so it
reminded me too of like
which is just so funny just to say
really quick how you said
um separation anxiety from your parents
i would always say like the only way i
know how to describe the feeling is like
homesick like have you ever like like
when you're like your parents leave like
sometimes my anxiety just like feels
like that but like my mom could like
literally be in the same room
but it's like i still have like that
feeling because it's just the only way i
describe it and so
sometimes like when i feel that and like
some
you think okay like maybe i don't know
why i'm triggered my therapist would
immediately say like you do know why
like you just
think like you don't want to think about
it but for something like social anxiety
i think that i even remember like right
probably before um before
quarantine um i had to go
to like maybe it was like during
quarantine i don't know i was doing
something safely okay let's
let's just get another one i was wearing
a mask anyway i was going somewhere for
the first time
like sober when there was gonna be like
other people drinking and so it was the
first time i had to like actually
deal with my social anxiety without
alcohol
and i just realized that like it was one
of those things where
i and i'm working a lot on this now
because i think a lot of my anxiety
just comes from the constant fear of
like i'm not good enough i'm not good
enough like i'm not worthy of like even
being good enough or like having needs
and like people caring whatever
and we're all so consumed with like what
other people think and especially
if you think about alcohol it's like
people getting sober their first thought
is like well what are my friends gonna
think and like
i just started like walking into this
party and being like literally
no one cares about you especially like
being in la and like i wasn't really
going to be with a bunch of friends i
was like
everyone here is a narcissist everyone
here sucks
i'm like just like that is the very
advice
we give that very advice on the show all
the time we say
no one cares about you but you no one
cares like everyone's so concerned with
themselves and it's like
i think the biggest thing too is just
having boundaries because i didn't have
boundaries before because
i mean i'm sure you can relate sophie of
like i want to fix every
everyone i want to make sure everyone's
having fun i put everyone before myself
and i started realizing i don't like no
one cares
what i'm doing everyone cares about
themselves and when i'm done
i can be done i can [ __ ] party and i
can go home
that's so interesting you say it like
that because it's like in my
case when i talk about anxiety and i
talk like i don't have social anxiety
but i do know what you mean about
no one cares my whole thing is like
where i'm at in life compared to where
everybody else is
and i have to get this in my head that
you are where you're supposed to be
and everyone else is too you may be
ahead of people at your age or you may
be behind
in what your mind thinks and so it's
like getting
out of that and realizing you are who
you are no one cares where you are
except themselves it gets better and it
cares so much about where they are
too and i think like the biggest thing i
learned from
working my way backwards through the
industry too
is and this is more like digital stuff
because like in reality like
people that aren't from la which is a
bunch of transplants like me like
no one knows what they're doing but i
just realized like because i'm someone
who i just asked questions
and one of my agents used to always say
like curiosity killed the cat and i was
like no it's making this cat [ __ ]
smart
and because i would always be like how
like who did this
like who funded this like how did this
happen and it wasn't because like i
wanted to like feel bad or like compare
myself necessarily
i was just always so curious because i
know there's so much more
behind an instagram post and the more
questions i ask and the more that i talk
to people and i'm like an open book like
i
help my friend start businesses all the
time and i'm just like
literally nine times out of ten what you
see on instagram is
smoke and mirrors like it just is like i
posted a bikini photo today
and i was crying an hour ago it's just
like
sophia i can't even get myself to take a
bikini photo
like eyeliner no by the way she didn't
even know i was doing it
i caught her off guard i was like okay
this is my
photo this is why i need to like hang
out with you guys and get the [ __ ] out
of my house because i have no one to
like snap pictures of me besides my
little brothers who like literally just
took a picture of me with like my nose
cast on like laying on the couch like
that's not instagram worthy
but it's just like i literally was on
facetime with my friend and i was like
i was like i know i i have a birthday
party on friday and i just want to look
cute i don't care what people think
about me
i want to look cute for me but i know 30
minutes later i'm going to be pissed off
because i couldn't even take an
instagram picture of it like why is this
our life
like it's it's it's life it's so dumb
it's like it didn't happen
if you didn't take a picture today no it
didn't happen
your birthday didn't happen all the time
i can't execute i can't execute i got a
fashion vlogger for you
oh my goodness it's like since he calls
me the queen of selfies because like 90
of my photos are just like classic
selfies
you know how to find the light which is
rare i will say
i'm the no i i'm worse than i think both
of you because i'm the type of person
that
i take great photos of everyone but no
one else can take it the way that i see
it for
myself so i get limit i'm like can't you
so
thank me to take a photo of it i will
set it up
i'll say sophia stand here do not move
take the phone and replace it
with your hands and i do stuff and i'm
like
[ __ ] no she's the scariest person to
take photos of just because
this is why i need this is why i need to
come over because i just need to like
take advantage of
sistine oh my god i'll take photos as
the director
and she'll position you i just like hate
having my picture taken it's like all of
a sudden i'm like i don't know how i got
here
because like all of a sudden i like have
an instagram and i'm supposed to post
pictures of myself there's nothing more
that i hate than taking photos of myself
so you wonder why i take your pics all
the time
because it's like i can like cover your
face and just show you what i'm wearing
but it's just but it's hard it's weird
it's so weird
i feel like and you i feel like i try to
tell myself i'm like i don't compare my
photos to like everyone else
and then i see the photo that kendall
jenner's posted she looks like a real
life barbie oh and you're yeah
all right i'll like save the photos and
i'm like remember this pose like you can
do it
and like it just never works i've never
had one
part that kills the confidence the most
when you save one
and you literally dress the same and
then it just does not look
anything i literally tried i tried i
had my phone i put my bikini on outside
let me recreate her whole thing because
i had a red bikini all the time
opposite this is the best because do you
like this photo i'm like your body looks
incredible but you're posing in front of
a bookshelf i'm like it doesn't really
look like
the correct background for a bikini pic
right now
i don't know about you it was it did not
work out because nobody takes
i couldn't i was posting it i was like i
can't do it outside the lighting's not
that good
so everything's better inside but like
who's wearing a bikini inside your
bookshelf like
you can make it i don't know what you do
in your free time
it might be a mood booster for you to go
to the library in your bikini
that's true oh my god so that is i think
the key to all this do not believe
anything we post on instagram because
it's all smoke and mirrors
it's all smoke and mirrors from like a
bikini pic to like a flourishing
business
like you're just going you don't know
it's true it's true and going back to
sort of you don't know what anyone's
going through i'll look at some of these
girls
pictures i'm like holy [ __ ] they're
beautiful i'm sure they have not a
single problem in the world because they
have a
body like that whereas they're probably
the ones the most insecure
so that's always interesting just to
like remind yourself and i think also
like
two i was just saying this on my podcast
because it was just valentine's day
and i was like i thought i was going to
be like
so upset and like a total basket case
and i was just like i was this person
last year on valentine's day
like i was the person with a long
caption with like the cute slideshow
and i was like and look at me now
[ __ ] i was like
you could be me in 12 months join the
club like
i love it i mean it's just like and my
real friends
are like the ones like facetiming me
being like my one of my girlfriends and
her boyfriend were like
oh yeah you liked my instagram don't
worry i almost deleted it because we got
a fight and i slept in the guest bedroom
last night like don't listen to anything
here on instagram
and i'm just like that's like the energy
we need you know what i mean it's like a
nice relationship is perfect
no one's life is perfect it's just you
know we should start
what go ahead sophia i was just gonna
say that
i think that's what i've realized the
most when i've started this podcast with
sistine is that
the more vulnerable we are because we
try to like shoot the [ __ ] with each
other and we're goofy and we like talk
conspiracy theories
but the moments we're like really open
about like anxiety or
stress or blah blah blah blah that's
when you get the most responses
yeah yeah people want to hear especially
right now like
i think we should start a new trend with
every instagram caption
that we write associated with the photo
you could write the truth of what either
went into the photo yes
like stuff like if it's a bikini figure
like i literally am so hungry i'm about
to eat a big mac after this hi
here it is like i already supposed to
baby kitty photo i had the worst
news like two hours ago this is just
literally like can you see the
bookshelves
warping towards me in the background i
mean that is one of my favorite
favorite hobbies this is i mean people
are way better at face tuning now but it
used to be like zooming into the lines
in the background of the photos
but no it's so it's it's so funny too
because it's just like
i feel like i always like have all these
photos that like i'll put on makeup like
once a week
and then because i also just like hate
wearing makeup and then i'll be like
posting a picture of me
and i like look like this in bed and i
always just want to write i look nothing
like this right now but i'm like i'm
gonna post that like every single photo
at this point so i think people just
understand
at that point you know there's moments
where i've had my girlfriends message me
because i'll put on like a really cute
outfit and i'll post it on my story and
then i'll change back into my sweatpants
look oh my god even festival this this
little do they know it took me like
probably 40 minutes to even decide
what this outfit was how stressed out i
was how angry it was to get that photo
and then go oh yeah i just like threw
this together like i
honestly i have to tell them that i'm
like you guys i'm not
this put together like i'm really not
the fashionista of the family like i all
have
one idea for one outfit okay so we'll
put like orange and pink together
i'm still not that good
i've told and if my friends are
listening to this i've totally tricked
them into thinking that i'm way like
more fashionistan like a makeup group
you're getting better i did that i
literally did that last week i
literally like put on like a cute er top
because like i'm that person that like i
love the idea of orange and pink
together but then if i put it on
i'm like i don't leave the house in this
like i'd cause i was talking to my
friends about it i'm like i don't know
what's wrong with me in a sense of like
i don't want people to like look at me
when i'm out in public like i don't want
to like look
like i'm something that i'm not like
that's hard me and my one good friend
like have this like
we're we're so weird about it it's like
i just want to look like i'm like not
trying like i don't want attention
and it's like also i'll put on something
for instagram and like i admire the
confidence that people have to like take
instagrams in public
wear fashionable outfits in public
because like unless there's a reason
like i am walking out of the house in a
t-shirt and jeans and that is the fancy
version of what i'm leaving my house in
like and that's what you like and it
works for you
it works it works you just like there's
enough like mental health to deal with
over here the last thing i need to worry
about
is like mixing patterns yeah i think
getting a good instagram want to argue
yeah
i feel like i've tried the trends of
like what tick-tockers are doing with
they're like their hair
pulled back and these like cute little
things and i shot i try to wear like the
plaid like crop top shirts
and i literally look like a baby
a giant baby a clown
like a child and yeah so i thought i
realized like
generation z versus millennials
light years like i'm sorry
i'm 26 and three quarters i'm about to
be 27 years old
like i there are some trends that i just
cannot partake in anything anyway i
heard skinny jeans are out
apparently which by the way i was just
thinking as i
looked at revolve because i don't know
if quarantine has done this to you but
like i'm actually in this
like phase now where i'm just like
actually ready like
to bust out i'm just like no i need like
a hot girl summer
you know what i mean yeah and i was like
literally
and i was like i think skinny jeans are
going to be my thing and then i was like
oh
now gen z says we can't wear them like
jesus christ
i know i never do anything right by gen
z by the way true
also also dark circles if i freaking
knew that
years ago that my dark circles were
going to be a [ __ ] trend
are you kidding me when i saw that on
instagram i was like this is a joke
right
like why do they want to look dead i
don't i don't get it it's like the grunt
darts
they're like pretty i look i love
freckles but it's like now they're
adding it
it's like it's yeah it's a lot and i
can't keep up
so you know what i'm just gonna keep
posting my bookshelf selfies
yeah literally literally stay true to
yourself
yeah i rewear the same outfit like 80
times i'm gonna continue wearing it
another 81st time
so that is it i changed about two to
three times a week
and my i had to change i have so many
pairs of gray sweatpants
because i just like neutral colors and
my little brother would not stop making
fun of me this week and he was like
hey stinky and i'm like first of all i'm
not
stinky and it's like he's like like he's
16 like
his sense of humor is like telling
people that they stink and that they
smell like there's a post-it note on the
top of my mom's ceiling right now that
says oh my god you
stink and like it's just like you're 16.
and so i could literally put on green
sweatpants in a nude
sweatshirt when i got out of the shower
yesterday because i was like i don't
want them to think that i've been
wearing the same gray outfit for the
past
five days so maybe we are branching into
some color
quarantine you're doing that to us yeah
and i have to say i was all revolved as
well
twice this morning and the section
the edit i was under was a night out
yes yes i'm trying i'm adjusting when we
get out of here
all of us we're going hard ladies
honestly
just be glad you don't have my cell
phone number like
sending you text is the only text
message i've been sending the past three
days
is like links to like new spring
collections being like i'm about to
stunt in this dress
watch me show up in april like i have
texted so many people that you have
i called gaia released their collection
i sent it to one of my girlfriends and i
said
see catch me in this [ __ ] orange
dress i dare you
like i just mean i just ordered a polka
dot dress from revolve i don't know why
i don't know where i'm wearing this
where are we going i don't [ __ ] know
but
it's honestly good for your mental
health i don't care about the bookshelf
or what it is but like
honestly a mood booster at this point is
to just like
feel hot because we've been inside for
so long wearing sweatpants and it's like
i feel like we all forgot that we're
like
these beautiful female vessels and maybe
it's like what heartbreak has done to me
because i'm just like trying to like
hype myself back up but it's about the
energy i'm taking it into the summer no
heartbreak like boosts you i know for me
i got blonder i got shaped
my style amped up i was like who am i
like everywhere
i've never looked better i've never
looked better i'm like
i'm like i didn't know that this was
going to like take me to a glow
up i'm like i'm dead inside but
i'm like i need a heartbreak every year
just like yeah
every january just every six months like
a tune-up
every six years because like when you
like quote unquote fall in love you like
gain weight and stuff and so i'm like
this is like
the total opposite i'm like everyone's
like you look amazing i'm like
huh yeah i actually do vacant inside but
you're like i'm dying
i am a shell of a human but i look good
i look good that's all we can ask for
right now
lauren i'll we'll leave you with this
one last question i was actually just
curious i didn't even write this down
because you're you're always branching
and doing leave your foot in like so
many different pawns
and i would love to know what you see
yourself doing
in like five years oh i mean
it's it's one of those things too i
think of the past year has taught me
anything
it's that i've accepted that i actually
may
may not know as much as i think i know
and i think that's really scary for
someone like me
and so i think it's like for me
it's understanding that like i don't
have to be
psycho in control like i have the past
10 years of my career
i can still like be active and partake
in life
and i think that what's meant so much to
me in my career the past year really has
been this like
authenticity and like being open and
honest and vulnerable and i think
my podcast was like the biggest silver
lining and so
i think if i could like literally in
five years just somehow
like i think at the core just like be
a good person and like enjoy what i'm
doing
which like i didn't do for a very long
time because it was always that scarcity
mindset of like i'm gonna have to move
back home i'm not gonna make it another
way
and so i think just like figuring out in
the next five years which is like for me
terrifying because like then i'll be
like in my 30s like
whoa i mean like let's hope like i won't
be like freezing my eggs and like maybe
just be pregnant like we don't
know those are the things by the way if
that happens that happens i feel like
you know exactly i get it though like
life happens when you're busy making
other plans and i think that that's one
thing that we've really learned this
year is that
do not expect anything that you like
do not plan anything because your life
can change
yeah one day in a second and like
literally
in a split second and it's like i it's
always like
man plans god laughs because it's like
you just have to like roll with the
punches so i think it's like for me like
in my career it's like
even i've had so many personal just
blows this year and like even
professional blows and i think the one
thing that's like
helped me is being honest about it all
and sharing it all
not in a way where it's like i'm
depleting myself and like my privacy but
i think that at least it's helped me
make this community and i finally feel
like i'm in this place where i'm an
adult on the internet whereas
not a 16 year old on the internet
anymore so just kind of figuring out
over the next few years of like okay how
do i now that i know who i
am and i know what i stand for just kind
of catapulting off of that
so i'm doing a lot of like writing and
designing stuff
and just planning little things but just
taking it
taking it day by day because you never
know when someone's going to drop kick
you in the face again you know
lauren that was a brilliant answer
thank you it's not it's not the most
exciting
thing no it is because but this next
chapter of your life
i'm so excited for it i'm so excited for
you because
you're doing so well and you're on such
a good path and like
yes you know you've dealt with hardships
and you've dealt with bad people and
getting drop kicked in the face but
you've bounced back
so well and like that really says
something about your character and
you're stronger because of it so i'm
really excited for you yeah
we love you i literally love you guys so
much
we love you thank you thank you for
having me yeah of course
seriously we absolutely love you yeah
where can everyone find you
i mean listen all you have to do is type
in lauren elizabeth in
any search bar i'm sure you can even say
it and all of a sudden your phone will
just start redirecting you there because
our phone says everything we say
but lauren elizabeth on instagram and
then there's mood with lauren elizabeth
the podcast
on youtube lauren elizabeth you'll
you'll find everything on instagram
there's a million things you can watch
listen to read all that stuff
perfect we love you thank you so much i
love you guys